Let's now turn to
the Pentagon for more on
what the Coast Guard says
will be a challenging mission
to find this
missing submersible
with its five people on board
again, 13,000 feet deep.
Oren, you're at the Pentagon.
Tell us more
about the different search capabilities
that are heading to that area.
Alex, a few different types of aircraft
taking part in this search,
each with their specific search
and rescue or search and recovery role.
First, both the U.S.
and the Canadians either have launched
or are ready to launch C-130 Hercules.
These are four
engine aircraft designed specifically
for long, range, long endurance patrols.
So they're able to stay up
for an extended period of time
and search the surface of the water,
whether that's for debris
or of the submersible surface
and lost communications.
So they're likely in charge of that role,
given that this could be quite a large
search area.
Canada has also launched a P-8 Poseidon.
Brian mentioned
this is a submarine hunter,
and that's what its specialty is.
It has different ways
of detecting the mass
of a body of metal underwater.
And that's what it will try to focus on.
The challenge here is that
this submersible
is far smaller than an enemy submarine.
But to its advantage,
at least this submersible
wants to be found.
One of the ways it will is with
what are called sonar buoys.
It drops these into the water
and these listen for any sound
or acoustic signature
sound obviously travels
very well underwater.
So these can hear from miles
in different directions.
And if there is some sound,
you can use
a few of these different sonar buoys
to try to essentially triangulate or zoom
in precisely
on the location of where
this submersible may be.
Crucially, for these to work,
the submersible
has to make some sort of sound.
So that's one of the key questions
that remains here.
Earlier today,
there was a press conference
from the Coast Guard.
They said
there are commercial ships on the way.
They will bring
additional search capabilities
and they'll keep those aircraft up.
A Canadian Coast
Guard ship is on its way, having left
Newfoundland a few hours ago,
according to Marine Traffic AECOM.
It's making its way south, southeast
towards the search site
towards where that submersible may be.
So it's still hours away.
But they've pointed out
that there are at least
theoretically, 96 hours
of survival capability
for the submersible So, Alex,
the clock is ticking.
The search assets are out there
very much looking to see if they can find
where this submersible may be.
Clock is ticking.
The search is on.
Oren Liebermann at the Pentagon,
thank you very much.
I want to now bring in retired Naval
Captain Bobby
Scully for more insight
on how the search and rescue effort
is unfolding.
Captain, thank you so much
for joining me.
We've been talking
about the depth of this water,
the distance
that this search site is from the coast.
900 miles off the coast
of Cape
Cod, a little bit less off
off the coast of Canada.
To what extent
is looking for this submersible
finally looking at its like
is it looking like
a needle in a haystack, if you will,
Well, thanks for having me, Alex.
And first of all,
I want to say my heart really goes out
to the crew of the submersible.
And and also I want to say
good luck
to all the men and women
that are out there searching.
But as with any
search and rescue operation out at sea,
it is a bit like searching
for a needle in a haystack.
But in this case,
unlike some of the rescue search missions
that I've been on for aircraft
in this case, they knew exactly
the location that they were starting with
with the submersible.
So they have put that on
for where to start the rescue,
but where to start the search.
And that's very important in this case.
So they know a starting point
the depth of water causes this to be
a much bigger locate area to search in.
So that's going to increase the haystack.
But they have
a lot of assets on station already
with the aircraft in the air
and they're bringing in all the
other resources that they need.
The sonobuoys are fabulous
to get into the water column,
and that's what they need to do
with having the depth of water that they
they are addressing.
So they have a lot of smart people
in the Coast Guard
and in the Navy
and some of the commercial assets
to get a multi-pronged approach
to start chipping away at this haystack.
And the 96 hours
is a short amount of time, but.
Right.
These resources are very effective.
Captain, you
you like the Coast Guard, Admiral,
we heard from earlier
did emphasize the importance
of sonar here.
What is it that those boys
and those capabilities
will be listening
for under the surface of the water?
How does that work?
Well, with the
sonobuoys they're listening to the sound
and the submersibles
going to be making sound itself with the
the systems on board,
the mechanical systems
and that sort of thing.
The crew hopefully are making a noise
this as well.
It can go back to,
you know, the movies that you watch.
You know, when we're hunting submarines,
you know,
the enemy
submarines are not making any noise
because they don't want to be.
They don't want to be found.
Well, in this case,
the submersible wants to be found.
So a system for running
the crew is making noise
and those sonobuoys are picking up.
They're very good.
And they're picking
they're detecting these noises.
I imagine that the other systems
that the ships are bringing
are the like side scan sonar
or that type of thing
that we use typically to pick up
metallic debris on the bottom floor.
In this case,
a metallic submersible,
which is a larger piece of metal.
And so
imagine that
we're
bringing in some of the side
scan sonar that
or the sonar that picks up metal
in addition to the sonogram
to detect the sound
So I don't know, but I would imagine
that between the military
and the Coast Guard
that they're bringing in this other.
Right.
It has now been more than 24 hours
since this submarine
and its five passengers went missing.
We understand that there is around
70 to 96 hours of air on board
that that's really the sort of extent
of that.
So are you
can you still hold out
hope or are you still optimistic
at this point that this submersible
can be found with its passengers alive?
Oh, absolutely.
I am,
because the hard part
is finding the submersible.
And once they find the submersible,
there's all sorts of situations
of how to get that submersible
to the surface
and can rescue the crew.
And there's many different options
that just come to my mind
and I don't have all the details
of what the situation is.
You know,
there is remote operated vehicles
that can get to that depth
and they can go down and,
you know, attach
something to the submersible
if the submersible
is without power.
And that could be part of the problem
with communications
and mobility on the commercial.
But we have remote operated vehicles
that can be gotten up to the scene
relatively
I don't want to say quickly,
but within that time period.
So there's all sorts of scenarios
that very smart people are looking at
that could recover that.
Well, we're certainly comforted.
Comforted by your confidence.
Retired Captain
Bobby Schooley, thank you very much
for your time.
And your perspective this evening.
Thank you, Alex.